a bangladeshi missile corvette and a
pakistani frigate both made in china
a country naval training ship built to
the anadolu shipyards in turkey
these ships and other naval equipment
are on display at hammock port in qatar
as part of dimdex the annual maritime
defense expo held in doha
defence companies from around the world
have gathered to show their latest wares
as potential buyers look for bargains
that will give their navies an edge in
any potential conflict a new class of
shipbuilder has emerged making stealthy
powerful warships at a price many
countries can afford
one of the newcomers china is now
expanding its defense base while
supplying cheap capable warships to its
clients
you have china
exporting submarines to
bangladesh you know in the southeast
asia they were exporting submarines to
even pakistan they are also having a
footprint in africa where there are
certain countries which have chinese
products like nigeria
so
in terms not only in terms of volume of
these vessels but also in terms of the
tonnage of the vessels that china has
now
diversified its you know
different classes of ship as well as its
construction
italy too has been building advanced
frigates for egypt and has been helping
qatar's navy expand significantly
turkey's navy is developing rapidly
under its domestic shipbuilding milgen
program
building its own warships but also
perfecting how to integrate foreign
weapons sensor and radar systems that go
together to make modern naval systems
joikie has been building ships for a
very long time
but since with milliamp program we had
the experience and the capability of
designing our
own ships
including the turkish subsystems which
can be integrated
turkey is now building warships for
qatar pakistan and the uae its sites
also firmly fixed on lucrative asian
markets like indonesia
cost and flexibility are the chief
factors for success here and these three
countries are now building an ever
increasing number of stealthy powerful
warships for tomorrow's navies
alex catopoulos al jazeera doha